Mẹo, tôi biết quốc gia là đình đứng mấy bà đã diễn ra tại quảng trường bảo tăng ở thủ đô Amstick Dam.
Nên giống sự khuy động mua hoa tôi biết nằm anh in không trao mi sống tại Hà Lan.
Điểm đặc biệt có lẽ hội em này là việc tôi chức chứng bày, hai chăm nghìn bông hoa tôi biết ngoài trời, ngày dưới chung tâm thành phố,
trong thời điện mà trở ư vấn đăng phải trải qua mô đông.
Khá bản tôi chứ, tuan bộ xong hoa đường lợi trọn thường nhữ giống, cho liếp chứ lợi cao, nở đồng ngoài,
nhằm tạo không sang thực dợ ở và trường tại thông nghiệp chào đón mùu xuân sắp tới.
Khá bởi kên em chừng đây, phải thầm quá nằm này không chỉ được chứ lướng mà còn được chức tiếp,
hai mô số bộm tôi biết mang về, khó đỏ tăng tính tương tăng và gần tiếp tục đồng với lẽ hội.
Ngày hoa tôi biết quốc gia đình xem là một sự kiện mở màn cho mua kinh shoạn hoa tôi biết,
môn ngành xuất khẩu chù lực của Hà Lan.
Cái bộ của Hà Hoa tôi biết Hà Lan, quốc gia này hiện là nhà sản xuất hoa tôi biết các cạnh lần nhất thế giới.